>> Laura: BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
EVERY NOW AND THEN A YOUNG
PERSON WILL POSE THE QUESTION
THAT EXPOSES THE INTELLECTUAL
LAZINESS AND ARROGANCE OF AN
ADULT IS TO POSTING ON OLD
CONNECTIONS.
THAT WAS OCCASIONED RECENTLY AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO WHICH
HOSTED AN EVENT CALLED
DISINFORMATION AND THE EROSION
OF DEMOCRACY.
WATCH HOW A COLLEGE FRESHMAN
GETS PANELIST WRITER IN
APPELBAUM TO REVEAL HER
WILLINGNESS TO COVER UP FOR THE
BIDENS.
>> IN 2020 YOU WROTE THOSE WHO
LIVE OUTSIDE THE FOX NEWS BUBBL
DO NOT NEED TO LEARN ANY OF THE
STUFF ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN
REFERRING TO HIS LAPTOP.
OPAL LATER AFTER THAT FOUND THA
IF VOTERS KNEW ABOUT THE CONTEN
OF THE LAPTOP 16 PERCENT OF JOE
BIDEN VOTERS WOULD HAVE ACTED
DIFFERENTLY.
YOU THINK THE MEDIA ACTED
INAPPROPRIATELY WHEN THEY
INSTANTLY DISMISSED THE LAPTOP
AS PART.
>> MY PROBLEM WITH THE LAPTOP I
TOTALLY IRRELEVANT FREIGHT IS
NOT WHETHER DISINFORMATION, I
DIDN'T THINK THE HUNTER BIDEN
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH WHO SHOULD
BE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
I DON'T FIND IT TO BE
INTERESTING.
>> OF COURSE SHE DOESN'T THINK
IT'S RELEVANT.
SHE'S JUST ANOTHER
SELF-APPOINTED ELITE WITH FAR
MORE WORRIED ABOUT TRIPS TO
EUROPE THAN THREATS TO THE
UNITED STATES.
NOT TO BE OUTDONE BY A FELLOW
NEVER TRUMP R, A FORMER
CONSERVATIVE SAYS THAT EVEN IF
BIG TECH IN THE MEDIA COLLUDED
TO CENTER THE HUNTER BIDEN STORY
, IT WAS NO BIG DEAL.
>> IF ONLY THAT MEDIA HAD TOLD
US ABOUT THE LAPTOP AT THE TIME
WHICH KID YESTERDAY WERE
SUGGESTING WHICH I DON'T BUY TH
THEORY, THAT TRUMP WOULD HAVE
WON.
BUT FOR THE CENSORING OF THE NE
YORK POST COMMODE TRUMP WOULD
HAVE ONE.
I THINK IT'S PREPOSTEROUS
COUNTER ATTACK.
>> AND TO THINK THAT HE ONCE
WROTE A BOOK CALLED LIBERAL
FASCISM.
AND WONDER WHAT HE THINKS OF
THAT BOOK TODAY.
GOLDBERG FIELDS TO MENTION THE
PULL SHOWING 16 PERCENT OF BIDE
VOTERS WOULD NOT HAVE VOTED FOR
HIM HAD THEY KNOWN ABOUT THE
TRUE HUNTER BIDEN STORY.
THE ONLY GOOD THING THAT CAME
OUT OF THIS CONFERENCE WHERE TH
YOUNG JOURNALIST WHO HAD THE
COURAGE TO CALL OUT THE MEDIA'S
GLARING HYPOCRISY THE FOLKS
ONSTAGE ARE ALL FRIENDS WITH
HIGH FLYERS AND BIG TECH AND ON
WALL STREET IN TO MAKE BILLIONS
IN CHINA.
THEY DON'T WANT OUR GOVERNMENT
TO DO ANYTHING TO UPSET THEIR
CASH FLOWS.
THEY ARE BOUGHT AND PAID FOR.
>> NOW CHINA POSED A LEADERSHIP
POSITION FOR THE WORLD AND MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS.
>> CHINA, THE WHOLE REGION IS A
VERY VERY EXCITING PLACE.
>> THEY CREATE WAYS TO SHOW.
>> NOW, IT'S NO WONDER THAT THE
DEFENSE INDUSTRY AND THE
JOURNALIST WHO NURSED AT THE
BLAZE AND SAVE THEIR HAWKISH
NOSE FOR RUSSIA OR MAKE IT THE
MIDDLE EAST FREIGHT THEY WANT T
ADVOCATE FOR THE U.S. DECOUPLIN
FROM CHINA EVEN AS THEY
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ONGOING THREAT
THAT CHINA POSES.
TO GET THERE IS JUST NO COUNTRY
THAT PRESENTS A BROADER THREAT
TO OUR IDEAS, OUR INNOVATION,
AND OUR ECONOMIC SECURITY THAN
CHINA.
>> HE IS RIGHT, SO WHY AREN'T
THEY LAYING OUT A STRATEGY TO
COUNTER THIS?
WHERE IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S PROFITS FOR
TATE ASIA?
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
THEY TESTIFIED THAT THE UKRAINE
CONFLICT WILL BE UNFOLDING FOUR
YEARS.
MEANWHILE, AS WE BLOW THROUGH
UNTOLD BILLIONS IN EASTERN
EUROPE, CHINA IS WORKING
OVERTIME TO MARGINALIZE AND
ULTIMATELY ECLIPSE THE UNITED
STATES MILITARILY AND
ECONOMICALLY.
NOW, WHEN WORD GOT OUT THAT
NANCY PELOSI WAS CONSIDERING AN
OFFICIAL VISIT TO TAIWAN, CHINA
RECENTLY WORN HER OFF.
>> IF HOUSE SPEAKER PELOSI
VISITS TAIWAN, IT WILL SERIOUSL
VIOLATE THE ONE CHINA PRINCIPLE
AND SERIOUSLY IMPACT THE
POLITICAL FOUNDATION OF THE U.S
CHINA RELATIONS.
CHINA IS FIRMLY OPPOSED TO THIS.
>> NOW, CHINA WOULD NEVER DARE
TAKE THAT THREATENING OF A
POSTURE UNDER TRUMP.
WE KNOW THEY WOULD NOT.
BUT WITH BIDEN, THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE ALL THE LEVERAGE AND
BASICALLY THEY DO.
IN YEARS AGO WITH HUNTER BIDEN,
THEY SAW AN EASY TARGET.
WHO BETTER THAN A NE'ER-DO-WELL
SON THAN A SITTING VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> THAT CAME UNBURIED LEAP.
LEAP.
HE'S THE
ONE WITH THE COMPUTER.
TO THEM EVERYWHERE.
>> IT WAS AN EASY SET UP TO GET
SOME CCP CONNECTED COMPANY TO
PUT HIM ON THE PAYROLL AND HOPE
THAT SOME OF THAT MONEY WOULD
ULTIMATELY TRICKLE DOWN TO A
PRINCIPAL, A.K.A. THE BIG GUY,
JOE BIDEN.
NOW, COULD THIS EXPLAIN AT LEAS
PARTIALLY WHY BIDEN HAS STILL
NOT UNVEILED AS SENSIBLE CHINA
STRATEGY?
WHY HE'S NOT HELD CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE AT ALL FOR ITS
DESTRUCTION OF THE EVIDENCE AT
THE WUHAN LAB?
>> HAD TO EXPLAIN THAT THEY HAV
SIGNIFICANT CIRCUMSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE THAT COVID 19
ORIGINATED IN THE LAB.
HAS THE WHITE HOUSE SEEN ANY
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT IT
DID NOT ORIGINATE?
>> I THINK FIRST I WOULD CAUTIO
YOU AGAINST THIS DISPROVING AND
NEGATIVE THERE WHICH IS NEVER
THE RESPONSIBLE APPROACH IN OUR
VIEW WHEN IT COMES TO GETTING T
THE BOTTOM OF THE ROOT CAUSES O
A PANDEMIC THAT HAS KILLED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> WE ARE LEARNING MORE EVERY
DAY ABOUT WHAT WAS ON THAT
LAPTOP AND ACCORDING TO
WHISTLEBLOWER JACK MAX B WHO
GAINED ACCESS OF THE HARD DRIVE
THERE'S A LOT MORE WHERE THAT
CAME FROM.
HERE IS WHAT HE TOLD DAILY MAIL
.COM.
>> ULTIMATELY WE FOUND 450
GIGABYTES OF WHAT HUNTER THOUGH
WAS RAISED MATERIAL AMONGST
THOSE THINGS WERE 80,000 IMAGES
AND VIDEOS.
SINCE THEN WE'VE FOUND THOUSAND
AND THOUSANDS OF PDFS WE DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT FREIGHT WE BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SCRAP
ALL THE ATTACHMENTS.
WE KEEP FINDING MORE AND MORE
THINGS.
SO THAT BECAME QUITE HORRIFYING.
>> HORRIFYING.
LET'S SEE HERE, IT'S ONLY US AR
MOST DANGEROUS ADVERSARY GIVING
MONEY TO THE SON OF THE MAN WHO
WAS HELPING RUN OUR CHINA POLIC
AT THE TIME.
WE KNOW BIDEN IS CAPABLE OF
CONDEMNING FOR AN ASSAULT
AGAINST HUMAN LIBERTY WHEN HE
WANTS TO.
>> WE ARE GOING TO KEEP RAISING
ECONOMIC COSTS AND RATCHET UP
THE PAIN
INCREASE THE ECONOMIC ISOLATION.
>> BUT THE RESIDENT XI HUMAN
RIGHTS IN CHINA, BARELY A PEEP.
>> I HAD A VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
CONVERSATION WITH XI AND I MADE
IT CLEAR TO HIM, HE MADE NO
THREATS, BUT I MADE IT CLEAR TO
HIM TO MAKE SURE HE UNDERSTOOD
THE CONSEQUENCES OF HIM HELPING
RUSSIA.
>> WHILE, I BET THAT REALLY
SCARED HIM.
THE PLAIN TRUTH IS WITHOUT
FINANCIAL BACKING, RUSH OUT
WITHIN THREE ABLE TO WAGE A WAR
IN UKRAINE.
IT SOMETHING IS HOLDING BIDEN
BACK FROM FORCEFULLY WARNING
CHINA NOT TO FUND RUSSIA'S
BRUTAL RAMPAGE.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY AND DELAWARE
IS INVESTIGATING HUNTER'S LAPTOP
.
MAYBE SHE WILL SHED SOME LIGHT
ON THIS.
IN WHAT PROMISES EXPLICIT OR
IMPLICIT DID HE HAVE TO MAKE TO
FEEL THEY DEAL AND DID SOME OF
THAT CASH END UP BENEFITING HIS
FATHER IN SOME WAY.
CONTRARY TO WHAT MS. APPLEBAUM
CONTENDED, THESE QUESTIONS ARE
VERY RELEVANT.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
WASHINGTON POST WHICH URGED
IMMEDIATE RECKONING OVER THERE
2020 BEARING OF THE HUNTER BIDE
LAPTOP STORY MOST OF THE PRESS
CARED.
NO ONE ON THE LEFT IS WILLING T
ISOLATE CHINA, EVEN AS THE CCP
IS THE INVISIBLE HAND.
THE RECENT THEY DON'T TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY IS BECAUSE THEY THINK
OF HIM AS SOMEONE WHO IS ON
THEIR PAYROLL.
OF HUNTER BIDEN WERE BEING PAID
OFF BY LEAD SAFE BOOT BUSINESSES
, EVERYONE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO FORM WOUL
CARE AND CARE A LOT.
AT THE FACT IS, THEY JUST DON'T
BELIEVE THEY GETTING PAID OFF B
THE CCP IS THAT BIG OF A DEAL.
THINK OF IT THIS WAY, JANUARY 6
IS A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY WORTHY
OF A TWO YEAR LONG INVESTIGATION
, BUT CHINA'S
VISION TO DOMINATE THE GLOBE,
THEY ARE CHOCKING HUMAN RIGHTS
ABUS